Shoot the new spider-man far from home trailer Oh just for you guys, exclusively Sam Jackson trailer. Yeah
I was so cool. Even though I got goosebumps. I was like
JT the main focus is for him to not be spider-man per se
But he gets dragged into it. But you know, he reluctantly saves the world again with Mysterio. Oh
Yeah, mr. Poster was a good guy in this they're both teaming up to kill it kill the game
To defeat all these elemental monsters. There are these threats to the worlds the elementals
elemental creatures and their and
mysterious um, you know, who who knows about them and wants to make sure that the world is safe from them and
And Nick Fury
asked him to come on and help because he's the only one who really sort of understands them in a way and and
Then you know he teams up with
Friendly neighborhood spider-man and unfortunately has to make him become more than just a friendly neighborhood spider-man cool
Black and gray suit we call the stealth suit, but I call it the comfy suit
It's a suit designed by Nick Fury
in order to
Do something that I'm not gonna tell you because it's a secret, okay
But it's really cool. It has all sorts of cool little features and for me as an actor
it was really interesting to try and figure out how spider-man would move and act in such different attire know his commitment his energy is
non-stop
Right, and I can feel him when he comes out there cuz he wants to tell all of you
everything about the movie and he knows that he can so it's mostly just us being like oh
You know and for me
I know there are a lot of movies, but this character Mysterio
when they showed it to me was so original and the idea and and who he is and why he's there is so original and
So special that for me. I was like man, they they did it again
You know, I didn't think they could and they do and they do it every time
Cool cool lights up it lights up like sometimes the lights don't always work light up the right way
They go disco colors there actually was one day where they all just started going different colors
And I can't see in that I can't see the lights
so you can see with and everyone would start looking at me like
It's really cool I mean the coolest thing about the suit is that there are some major secrets in it
Yeah, totally pretty cool. Hey everybody. It's Charlie
This is gonna be my breakdown of the spider-man far from home Comic Con panel
And the trailer that they showed Sony and Marvel aren't allowing any of the footage to be posted online
So I had to make this in a roundabout way
Like they say during that interview they gave away a whole bunch of really big details that make the film sound bigger and way
Weirder than I ever possibly imagined and quite a bit different from the comics. So I just broke this down top-10 style
There's a new brand of that IMAX ticket giveaway going on - all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave your favorite moment from their comic-con panel on the video
So starting with number 10, the trailer itself didn't acknowledge anything from infinity war or Avengers endgame
It doesn't place itself in the timeline at all
If you're like the one person on the planet that did not see infinity war you saw spider-man
Homecoming and then you watch this footage. You wouldn't be able to tell that anything crazy had happened
So that's just a step around spoilers. They obviously don't want to give away anything from the end of Avengers 4
I would expect them to continue that theme with all the future trailers that they drop because this isn't coming out till July well after
Avengers 4 9 you start out with the Mysterio reveal you see him in the suit
Obviously Jake Gyllenhaal was talking about the suit itself having a lot of secrets
But the twist in how it's created where it comes from and what his character is all about is very different from the comics
so number eight one of the biggest surprises is that the villains of the movie at least at the beginning of the movie are
Touted as these elemental monsters. There are elemental characters in Marvel Comics history, but they're super deep cut from the Doctor Strange
Comics so obviously spider-man has crossed over with Doctor Strange in the comics before but here's the thing about that
I think that there's all a big trick that Mysterio is pulling because of the abilities that he has in the comics
He's the master of illusion. So just keep that in the back of your mind 7 really big change
This is actually a pretty big deal
Mysterio starts out as a hero through most of the film as the actors describe him unless they're being blatantly misleading
He's one of the only people that understands the threat of these elemental creatures
so Nick Fury is the one that tasks him with joining shield because one of Nick Fury's primary jobs is also to
Protect the earth the same way that Doctor Strange does but on a more non mystical level then number six
Obviously because he's a villain in the comics and they're starting out with a very strange story
They might be trying to Winter Soldier him because Jake Gyllenhaal also said at this big Comic Con panel
That the core of the movie is his relationship with spider-man so they start out buddy-buddy
Think about what might happen later in the film to cause a falling out and what might turn
Mysterio to the dark side of the force so that he becomes a villain in future movies like if you're Mysterio
And you're not totally all there up top, but you have great skills. Think about it this way
Mysterio has faked other villains to make himself look like a hero when he takes them down
So what if these special elemental creatures that only he understands are his own?
creations and that's why he's the only person that understands them and eventually
Spider-man finds out about that and has to take him down like you would any other villain
So just imagine the mental gymnastics
Going on in Mysterio's head that he feels like he has a relationship
With Peter Parker, and he's trying to be a hero
We don't know exactly how crazy he is because the way they write all these Marvel villains has been getting better and better
Like kill monger is just the latest example in an evolution of a style of Marvel villain
So if Mysterio is trying to Gaslight Nick Fury in gaslights
Spider-man into thinking that he's a hero because he's helping take down these crazy giant creatures
But then winds up being the person to have created them it is gonna be spectacular
So even though the way they talked about the movie, it sounds very different from the comments in reality
They're using a very classic Mysterio comic-book twist faking things to make people think that you're better than you actually are
But even though we don't know how they're gonna end the movie or what the future of Mysterio is in the MCU
Because Jake Gyllenhaal is such a big get and he has such great energy with Tom Holland and the other actors on screen
I think they're gonna try and keep him around for as long as possible
Number 5 one of the other first scenes that we saw in the trailer was a Peter in his spider-man costume
Hugging Aunt May then going on his European vacation with his class
It's most of the characters from his debate team like we've seen in all the behind the scenes Martin stars. Mr
Harrington is one of the chaperones taking them all over place. I mean it's a European trip, but they're also learning as they go
It's meant to be a vacation like he's trying to not be
Spider-man but then number four as jake gyllenhaal said Mysterio working with Nick Fury to take down the threat of these elemental creatures
ropes spider-man in a very reluctant Peter Parker
So he has to go back on the clock again as a superhero with some special upgrades for Nick Fury
So three they're officially calling the new spider-man noir looking suit the stealth suit Tom Holland joked about it a little bit they did not
Say what the name of the brand-new upgraded?
stark tech suit is going to be with the red and black the funny thing about Tom Holland though is that he says that they
Make that special stealth suit for a reason that he can't tell us special function
But it's called a stealth suit
The reason why you would wear it is so that you would go undetected by the villains
I think when he was talking about that he was just talking about the larger plot line that he gets involved in while he's wearing
That suit but we've seen a lot of behind the scenes with him and Mysterio in that fight on the big
Carousel and - there was a whole bunch of Nick Fury
Like they said Tom Holland got goosebumps because he's being a badass like Nick Fury normally is remember all the crazy stuff
He did during Winter Soldier
especially that opening scene with a car he gets to do stuff like that during the movie but a lot of his functions are mostly
support functions helping spider-man in helping Mysterio
That was a really funny scene with Nick Fury bust into their hotel room while they were getting ready to sleep and darts
Ned leads in the neck so that he passes out so he can talk to Peter Parker and he sits down and says so I
finally get to meet the
spider-man like he's trying to make fun of him a little bit the same way that he used to make fun of Iron Man like
Iron Man thought of himself as a pretty important person Peter Parker kind of thinks of himself as a big deal because he's an Avenger
now so they're just
continuing that funny dynamic and then there are a couple scenes of Peters developing romance with Michelle throughout that European vacation that just develops through
The film and then number one the only real big climactic footage that they had in it was of Mysterio in a big battle in
His suit and even though he didn't say too many things about it. Yes, there is a version of a fishbowl
There was no mention of Ironman
Like I said, no big spoilers for Avengers 4 or anything like that
But the way they talk about it makes it feel like this film is more connected to the larger MCU than ever
So if you were worried about spider-man's future in the MCU after this
Hopefully that makes you feel a little better because they do have to Rin
They're sharing arrangement after this movie premieres before they make that third spider-man film, but big question for you guys
Let me know in the comments
What do you think about them starting out with Mysterio being a hero in the MCU in his slow?
Potential descent to sinister six villain, they didn't say exactly when they're gonna drop all this footage online
But it sounds like it's either gonna be next week or the week after that before the end of the year if I hear any
Big details about that. I'll be sure to include it in a future Marvel video, but I'll be doing some new Avengers for tomorrow
so leave all your requests in the comments while you wait for everything click here to re-watch the Avengers 4 trailer a
Billion more times and click here to rewatch the Captain Marvel trailer. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight